>>> WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
HAPPY THURSDAY.
WHY THE DEMOCRATS SO ANGRY.
IT DOESN’T SEEM TO MAKE ANY
SENSE.
IN NOVEMBER, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WON EVERYTHING, FULL
CONTROL OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THEY SEIZED FOR YEARS WHILE THEY
WERE OUT OF POWER.
THAT MADE SENSE.
WINNING SEEMED TO ENRAGE THEM
EVEN MORE.
DID YOU WATCH DEMOCRATS ON
TELEVISION TODAY AT THE
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
THEY ARE CRAZY PEOPLE, YELLING
AND MAKING THREATS.
IT IS BIZARRE.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY WOULD GET
TO WORK FIXING THE COUNTRY THEY
INHERITED.
THEY PROMISED TO DO THAT.
INSTEAD, THEY TALKED ABOUT
BREAKING THINGS AND HURTING
PEOPLE.
MAYBE IT IS INTRINSIC.
THERE IS A CERTAIN LOW-CHARACTER
PERSON WHO BECOMES MORE VICIOUS
IN VICTORY.
THERE WAS NEVER A REASON TO KILL
PEOPLE THAT WERE CAPTURED.
THEY DID IT BECAUSE THEY ENJOYED
IT.
ADAM SCHIFF AND NANCY PELOSI
HAVE A LITTLE BIT IN THEM.
IMAGINE BEING ADAM SCHIFF’S
LANDSCAPER OR NANCY PELOSI’S
HOUSEKEEPER.
IMAGINE HOW THEY TREAT THE STAFF
WHEN NO ONE IS WATCHING.
IMAGINE WAITING OWN THEM IN A
RESTAURANT.
HOW WOULD THEY TIP?
THEY FLATTER THE BOSS AND SCREAM
AT THE INTERN.
THEY SUCK UP AND SPIT DOWN.
JEFF BEZOS IS A GOD TO THEM.
YOU MEAN NOTHING.
NATURALLY, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS CONSTRUCTING A WORLD DESIGNED
TO SERVE JEFF BEZOS.
YOU ARE AN AFTERTHOUGHT IN THAT
WORLD.
IF YOU GET IN THE WAY, THEY WILL
PUNISH YOU.
THEY ALREADY ARE.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO SAY AND
THINK WHAT YOU WANT AND READ AND
WATCH WHAT YOU WANT, THREATENS
THEM ABOVE ALL.
WHY?
IF YOU HAVE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION, YOU CAN FORM YOUR
OWN JUDGMENT, JUDGMENTS THAT ARE
INDEPENDENT OF THEIRS.
A FREE INTERNET IS THEIR ENEMY.
THEY STARTED A SWEEPING MASS
CAMPAIGN.
YESTERDAY, GOOGLE PULLED A
PRO-LIFE NEWS SITE OFF OF
YOUTUBE.
WHY?
BECAUSE GOOGLE SUPPORTS
ABORTION.
CHILDREN DISTRACT THE LABOR
FORCE.
IF YOU ARE RAISING YOUR FAMILY,
YOU ARE NOT SERVING
SHAREHOLDERS.
GOOGLE DOESN’T WANT TO DEBATE.
THEY JUST SHUT IT DOWN.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
SUBSCRIBERS TO LIFE SIDE NEWS
WILL NO LONGER BE WATCHING
VIDEOS THAT QUESTION ABORTION,
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO.
TODAY, TWITTER SHUT DOWN JAMES
O’KEEFE’S PROJECT VAR I TAS.
THERE WAS NO JUSTIFIABLE REASON
TO DO IT BUT NO ONE IN THE MEDIA
ASKED QUESTIONS.
PROJECT VERITAS HAS BEEN KNOWN
TO SPREAD MISINFORMATION,
POLITICO ANNOUNCED IT.
THE PERSON THAT WROTE THE
SENTENCE, CHILD REPORTER, ANNA,
WHOSE TWITTER HANDLE BRAGGED SHE
WENT TO CORNELL, DIDN’T BOTHER
TO EXPLAIN WHAT THAT SO-CALLED
MISINFORMATION WAS.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS?
PROJECT VERITAS HAD CRITICIZED
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE.
ANNA DIDN’T QUESTION THAT
CHARGE.
SHE SEEMED PLEASED TO PLAY A
ROLE.
GOOD WORK, AN IN.
YOU WORK AT POLITICAL NOW.
YOU GET TO BE AMERICA’S ROOM
MONITOR AND TELL THE REST OF US
WHAT TO SAY.
ALL THE CHILD REPORTERS FEEL
THAT WAY.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE IN FAVOR OF
IT.
PROJECT VERITAS IS OFF TWITTER.
THEY ARE NOT SATISFIED.
THEY WILL NOT REST UNTIL THERE
IS NOT A SINGLE HUMAN BEING WHO
QUESTIONS ANY OF THE PLAT TUDS
THAT THEY MEMORIZED.
DIFFER VERSETY IS OUR STRENGTH,
TRANS RIGHTS ARE HUMAN RIGHTS.
THEY ACCEPT WHAT EVER THE
CENTRAL COMMITTEE DECIDES IS THE
SLOGAN OF THE DAY AND ANYONE
THAT MOCKS OR DISAGREES IS
SILENT.
IN THE NAME OF DIVERSITY, WE
MUST HAVE UNIFORMITY.
OF ALL THE IMPEDIMENTS OF
ACHIEVING THIS GOAL OF
UNIFORMITY, WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
CENTURIES OF TRADITION, THE
FIRST AMENDMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTION, THE FACT THAT THIS
WAS A FREE COUNTRY, OF ALL OF
THOSE, THIS CHANNEL, FOX NEWS,
IS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT HURDLE
TO GETTING EVERYONE TO SING FROM
THE SAME SONG SHEET.
FOX IS THE LAST BIG ORGANIZATION
IN THE AMERICAN NEWS MEDIA THAT
DIFFERS FROM THE OTHER NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS, THE ONLY ONE.
THERE IS EVERYONE ELSE STANDING
IN CRISP FORMATION IN THEIR
STARCHED MATCHING UNIFORMS IN
LITTLE CAPS PATIENTLY AWAITING
ORDERS FROM THE BILLIONAIRE
CLASS.
THERE IS FOX NEWS OFF BY
THEMSELVES OCCASIONALLY SAYING
THINGS SLIGHT DIFFERENT FROM
EVERYONE ELSE.
THERE ARE STILL JOURNALISTS
WILLING TO THINK FOR THEMSELVES
AND BRAVE ENOUGH TO SAY SO OUT
LOUD.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT’S WHAT
JOURNALISM SHOULD BE BUT IN
2021, IT IS VERY RARE AND THE OL
I GARKS HATE IT.
JEFF BEZOS HAS SENT HIS PERSONAL
DESCRIBES TO END FOX NEWS.
THEY HAVE WRITTEN A NUMBER OF
COLUMNS SUGGESTING THAT FOX NEWS
MUST BE SILENCED.
THEY HAVE GONE ON TELEVISION TO
DEMAND THAT FOX NEWS IS
SILENCED.
HERE IS ONE OF HIS EMPLOYEES.
>> THERE ARE OTHER OPTION,
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT CABLE
OPERATORS, LIKE COMCAST AND
CHARTER, WHICH SEND OUT TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE,
THEY CAN DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE WAY THAT FACEBOOK AND
TWITTER HAVE DONE.
THERE IS ALSO THE POSSIBILITY OF
REVIVING THE FAIRNESS DOCTRINE.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF WAYS TO
SILENCE FOX NEWS, HE HAS
EXPLAINED ON TELEVISION AND IN
COLUMNS.
HE DOESN’T CALL IT SILENCING FOX
NEWS.
HE SAYS, WE MUST DEMAND SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY.
MAKE IT GO AWAY, GET IN LINE.
NO MORE UNAUTHORIZED QUESTIONS,
NO MORE CRITICIZING JEFF BEZOS.
HE IS NOT THE ONLY ONE SAYING
IT.
IN THE LAST 30 DAYS, A SINGLE
COLUMNIST AT THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" CALLED NICK CHRISTOPHE
HAS WRITTEN THREE SEPARATE
COLUMNS DEMANDING THAT SOMEONE,
PLEASE, YANK THIS NEWS CHANNEL
OFF THE AIR IMMEDIATELY.
JUST YESTERDAY, CHRISTOPHE
SUGGESTED THAT THIS SHOW, THE
ONE YOU ARE WATCHING, WAS
SOMEHOW GUILTY OF TERRORISM, OF
VIOLENCE, SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN
OPPOSED TO CONSISTENTLY FOR FOUR
YEARS.
HOW ARE WE GUILTY YAND?
ASHLEY BABB, THE UNARMED
PROTESTER OCCASIONALLY WATCHED
THIS SHOW FROM TIME TO TIME AT
8:00 P.M.
ASHLEY BABOT IS DEAD.
SHE PAID QUITE A PRICE FOR
ENTERING THE SPEAKER’S LOBBY
WITHOUT PERMISSION AND NO ONE
MOURNED HER.
WE ARE SAYING THIS AS A SHOW.
NOW, WE NEED TO BAN ANY
TELEVISION SHOWS THAT ASHLEY
BABBOTT MIGHT HAVE WATCHED.
WE NEED TO CLOSE THE PAIN DOWN.
JOHN WAYNE CASEY LIKED THE NICK
CHRISTOPHE COLUMN SO HE IS
GUILTY OF MASS MURDER.
THAT’S WHAT HE IS SAYING.
WE WOULD NEVER SAY SOMETHING
LIKE THAT EVER.
IT IS TOO STUPID.
NOTHING IS TOO STUPID FOR NICK
CHRISTOPHE OR "THE NEW YORK
TIMES."
WHAT CHRISTOPHE LACKS IN REASON
HE MAKES UP FOR WITH VEHEMENT.
HE CAN’T STAND THAT SOMEONE
SOMEWHERE MIGHT BE FORCIBLY
DISAGREEING WITH HIM.
IT WOULD BE NICE IF HE SAID IT
OUT LOUD.
I’M CALLING FOR CENSORSHIP.
BE A MAN AND ADMIT WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
OF COURSE, HE WILL NOT DO THIS.
THESE ARE NOT MEN BUT CRAVEN
SERVANTS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, FELINE, NOT CANINE.
ALL OF THEIR AGGRESSION IS
PASSIVE AGGRESSION.
WATCH ANOTHER SLOPE-SHOULDERED
TOOL OF THE OL I GAURKY FAN
CENSORSHIP.
>> TUCKER CARLSON IS TELLING
VIEWERS THAT THIS NETWORK, CNN,
IS TRYING TO FORCE FOX NEWS OFF
THE AIR, WHICH IS PASSIVELY
FALSE.
WHILE SOME CRY CANCEL CULTURE,
LET ME SUGGEST A DIFFERENT WAY
TO THINK ABOUT THIS, A HARM
REDUCTION MODEL.
REDUCING A LIAR’S REACH IS NOT
THE SAME AS CENSORING FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS DIFFERENT
THAN FREEDOM OF REACH.
>> OH, LET ME SUGGEST A
DIFFERENT MODEL, THE HARM
REDUCTION MODEL.
NOTICE THE SEE DUCK TIFFLY
IMPRECISE LANGUAGE.
IT IS NOT A FASHCIOUS CRACKDOWN
ON FREE SPEED BY THE RUTHLESS
AND POWER-MAD BILLIONAIRES BUT
JUST HARM REDUCTION LIKE